some major revelations expected on why
the fbi searched former president
trump's home for hundreds of classified
documents allegedly taken from the white
house a judge has ordered the bureau to
explain their reasoning for the
mar-a-lago search with appropriate
redactions that deadline to unseal the
document is now just hours away and it
follows a request by cbs news and others
to make it public robert costa is not
far from the federal courthouse in west
palm beach florida for us this morning
bob many people waiting to get another
piece of this puzzle
good morning the justice department has
until noon today to release a redacted
version of the affidavit to the public
now there could be heavy redactions this
is an ongoing probe but it could still
offer new insight into why fbi agents
arrived at former president trump's home
search warrant in hand
almost three weeks after the fbi search
of former president trump's mar-a-lago
home a federal judge in florida ordered
thursday that the justice department
release the redacted affidavit behind
the search judge bruce rinehart wrote
that he approved the doj's suggested
redactions to the affidavit to protect
the identities of witnesses law
enforcement agents the investigation
strategy direction scope sources and
methods and grand jury information what
the public is going to learn is again
just how much effort went into this
affidavit the fact that there are pages
and pages and pages of probable cause
justice department officials had opposed
releasing the full affidavit saying
earlier this week they are very
concerned about the safety of the
witnesses involved in their
investigation into trump's alleged
mishandling of classified information
some of which went up to the level of
top secret legal experts say even though
the public will only likely see a
heavily redacted version it could still
be revealing it may also give some
details about how long this
investigation has been going on whether
it's been going on for months or whether
it's been going on for a year the
benefit of transparency is going to be
to let everybody know exactly what took
place and to prevent people from trying
to guess what's going on here
former president trump has called for
the affidavit to be released he was
conferring yesterday with his lawyers in
bedminster new jersey and keeps
insisting in social media posts that he
has done nothing wrong his legal team
has a deadline today to file more
information about why it has requested a
so-called special master or neutral
party to review the evidence
all right bob thank you very much we
know you'll stay on it for us